bonjour il en faut trouver
soyez les bienvenus on trouve facilement
avant c'est devenu un endroit
internationalement connu un jeudi dans
et pour l'année en cours
ça va on est content d'arriver à temps
et si je vois un truc max pourquoi les
chinois ou les japonais ils ont besoin
de fabriquer ça ici je crois nous avec
capable de faire ce sont des gens qui
ont vu la chose d'une manière totalement
industriel et il fabrique des poupées
gonflables comme il fabrique des petits
canards pour aller à la plage pour les
gamins avec les mêmes procédés les mêmes
matériaux etc
alors ça ça ne ressemble à rien si
horrible manifestement horrible est bon
mais non pas que tu fais ça tu vois il
ya maintenant parce qu'une dizaine
d'années presque une dizaine d'années
[Musique]
des bouteilles d'eau voilà alors c'est à
un système relativement simples qu'on a
pris parce que toutes les poupées sont
gonflés way ou moins pendant une nuit
avant d'être mis dans le commerce ou
être certain qu'ils aient 28 et c'est
donc on a un souci de la qualité alors
là elles sont sur l'envers donc il faut
pas regarder l'aspect de finition
puisque là elles sont sur l'envers il
apposera retourner pour donner cette
tour de latex très brillant très lisse
et très agréable au toucher elles sont
au tourne à l'envers c'est pour ça que
oui on dirait vraiment que c'est des
mecs
oui mais c'est simplement ce congrès
sera remis à l'endroit c'est de tout
vérifier qu'elles n'ont pas c'est très
bizarre de le voir une que cette ombre
et surtout deux lacs ont dégonflé très
fort ouais pour être certain qu'elle ait
aucune fuite
en fait ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
qu'on n'a jamais vus qu'à l'être humain
avoir une queue derrière une que nous
avons comme ça à moins que ce ne soient
pas les siens c'est pas des êtres
extraordinaires c'est un peu comme
jacques pradel continuer quantité à
l'extra terrestre situé à st le profil
du joueur c'est extraordinaire voilà
comment y alors là haut il ya toute la
chaîne de fabrication de poupées un
d'accord c'est le moulage là où voilà
alors là c'est entièrement donc tu te
rends pas en fait tu trouves le moule
dans le fût de la terre natale en latex
tu ressors et après tu d'école le latex
du moule c'est ça c'est fait une par une
voilà tout a nagé compressé ça y est
j'ai tout compris
ils sont tendues les unes at elle son
corps braire all blacks grâce à mal sa
magnifique tu veux dire des bossales
sont bien cambrai souvent oui
ah oui c'est très très joli film un
tracé qu'est ce que c'est beau alors oui
oui jean claude bossard c'est un rêve
c'est grossesse et la danse et le latex
qui sèche en fait qu'on voit la norme et
où le processus est automatisé way est
bon sur cette chaîne représente à peu
près huit mois de travail près de 2
millions d'investissements et ça c'est
le bal de la chasse est influent avec du
latex mais c'est encore tout et après tu
d'école le latex du mois là on est
d'accord pas d'accord c'est une beauté
total c'est une oeuvre d'art on sent un
marché brisant la glace
[Musique]
nous sommes les mannequins
tous
faisant tout cas pas à l'intérieur de la
ville sont minimales
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linda hardy tube abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus